John wig chapter three Parabellum takes
audiences even further into a world of
assassins intrigue and headshot after
head shot while reviews have been strong
it's not without its flaws let's break
down the highlights and lowlights of
John wick Chapter three right from the
start
Chapter three feels different than his
predecessors largely thanks to the
inclusion of a ticking clock elements
while John was never particularly
leisurely about conducting business
during the previous two movies he did
usually feel like he had some room to
breathe but any sense of leisure has
completely thrown out the window in
Parabellum which opens with a hero who
is wounded where he and on the run
watching a man with his back against the
wall makes the audience rout extra hard
for him as ever more dire circumstances
tax his wits and the world to survive
tick tock miss to it even after the man
on the run plot gets resolved the movie
still ends on a tense note with a
thrilling siege on the previously
impregnable continental putting the good
guys in the defensive position as the
high tables hit them with everything
they've got
would you help set the mood for a new
gift let us begin
previous antagonists for John wick have
all been very impressive all the
particulars of each character differed
they all felt like peers to John sharing
a sense of professional rivalry courtesy
and mutual respect they were calm cool
and had their own agendas often feeling
like they were starring in their own
equally interesting narratives running
parallel to John's which really helped
sell the idea of this falling world of
workman like assassins
yeah you
yeah but despite embodying a sense of
calmness coolness and world-building the
third movie's adjudicator character is a
jarring presence working on behalf of
the high table her scenes have a
tendency to grind the movie to a halt
and she plays detective two events we've
already seen him fold
unlike other supporting cast members
like Winston sharone or the Bowery King
the adjudicator has a serious deficit of
character and charm the only reason she
exists is to serve as a threat to John
Wick's allies giving the people who we
know like John a reason to continue
doing the right thing by him while he's
on the run she feels like a walking plot
device basically because that's all she
is
and compared to previous villains in the
series she's a serious step down if
there's one thing you absolutely cannot
count as a knock against John wick three
is the action sequences which are
hands-down the best and most creative
set pieces in the entire series even
more than the previous movies Parabellum
is a fight scene delivery system and we
mean that as a compliment what keeps the
wall-to-wall action from ever getting
tell at least for the most part is the
sheer variety going on in these
kill-or-be-killed conflicts are you
bored with pistol basic gun foo
well how about everyone just throws
knives at each other for a while do you
want to see a horse use as a weapon and
then a getaway vehicle how about a
motorcycle chase and the you at all
curious about what might happen if we
combine the horse action with the
motorcycle chase the results may
surprise you and they'll definitely keep
you engaged there is one exception to
the otherwise sterling action scenes in
Parabellum and that's the movies we had
number of fight sequences that don't
involve John wick Parabellum cuts away
to see what the villains are up to is
some frequency following a team of
basically ninjas working on behalf of
the adjudicator doing battle with John
Wick's allies these scenes that are
essentially henchmen versus henchmen
occasionally get kind of boring since
the audience just isn't invested in the
survival of any one combatant none of
these scenes invite the same enthusiasm
as a fight featuring John wick the only
person who we all really want to see get
out of the movie alive more the stunt
work in these scenes are still top-notch
they leave the viewer with a slightly
disengaged feeling not caring about the
outcome like watching a video game play
itself the fights that don't involve
John work maybe the weakest parts of
Parabellum but there is one big
exception Ally very Sofia the foot upon
world where we dug lover from John's
shadowy past is given plenty of room to
be established as capable
interesting her presence allows for not
only the series first co-op fights but
also an opportunity to get her
incredible dogs in on the action not
only do the dog fight moments from the
series full circle at least when it
comes to the puppy thing it's also just
a rare treat to watch trained dogs tear
into stunt performers with expert
precision while human combatants
continue to fight around them
it's interspecies choreography of a
rarely seen swords probably because it
looks really difficult to execute
rather than stealing the spotlight or
feeling shoehorned in Sofia holds her
own as a totally believable equal to
John she also doesn't overstay her
welcome she greets a hero by shooting
him gripes to him helps him kill like 50
people and leaves him with one final
insult before dipping out of the movie
never to be seen again it's somehow all
comes off as charming and leaves you
wanting more good to see you too the
first John wick has one tight screenplay
keeping things simple while hinting at a
tantalizing world just beneath the
surface the second movie further
established two roles on the history of
this weird wild in the ground in a way
that occasionally veered into the realm
of the ludicrous by the end of the
second movie is fair to wonder if
there's anybody in New York City who
isn't an international hitman but all of
this gets significantly escalated in
Chapter three which expands a well to
the point of absurdity this third longer
feels like a heightened but
theoretically possible world it feels
like the Hogwarts School of karate and
bloodshed there's an ever-expanding
compendium of significant coins and
tokens a clandestine dance academy slash
wrestling school run by a chrome Lord
and obscure rituals of branding and
finger chopping that land with an
element of randomness at times the plot
turns are so I'll to step with anything
resembling reality that they become
downright surreal such as Jon's days
long aimless walk through an endless
desert it's all just too much and you
wonder just how much more exotic things
can really become it gets to the point
where if the next movie sees John wick
having to go to the literal moon for
some reason you feel like he wouldn't be
all that surprised from start to finish
John wick three serves a beautifully
choreographed crowd-pleasing honestly
just insane fights that are clear
easy-to-follow and immensely satisfying
to watch unfold it's incredible to see
what appears to be accomplished in
camera in this movie where lesser action
films are the skies fight sequences with
hundreds of cuts and rapid editing
Parabellum that sings
with stuns proceeding and single shots
as though to signal to the viewer that
yeah we really did that despite how
stylized the movie is all of the fights
feel real and brutal whether you're
watching John wick insert the sharp part
of a knife into the soft part of an
eyeball also fierce dogs record growing
after groin it's just awesome to behold
there's a reason why Parabellum has a
ballet motif more than ever these action
scenes come off like precise
performances of a violent dangerous
dance the concept of Parabellum is
simple John wick is on the run it's a
solid hook to hang a story on and the
idea of John wick having to escape from
New York while all of New York tries to
kill him is irresistible so it's weird
when this compelling plot gets wrapped
up in pretty anti-climatic fashion after
trudging his way through the desert
until he collapses John wick is found
and transported as if by magic to a
summit with an elder of the high table
his hope is to negotiate in order to
nullify the bounty on his life
shockingly this is all granted without a
lot of arguments Oh John asked to do a
slice his ring finger off give up some
jewelry and promised to kill Winston
which he totally doesn't even kind of
plan on doing it's hard to tell exactly
when the John wick movies became the
sexiest series in action filmmaking the
first one followed a grieving hero as he
smashed stabbed and shot his way through
a series of somewhat grounded locales
the locations were all richly decorated
but they also weren't anything we
haven't seen before building up to a
quick and dirty showdown at the ugly
rain-drenched docks but something got
switched up in the second movie which
increasingly began portraying John
Wick's world is a super stylish place of
infinite mirrors trippy lights and 4k
Ultra HD Winamp of visualizers that's a
trend that continues in Parabellum to
the movies benefit from the neon pink
aesthetics of the NYC exteriors to the
Continental secret acid trip chamber
John wick is a movie where every
location is designed to impress whether
they come off as realistic or not the
John wick movies have never been
completely realistic but the Train
really leaves a station on that front in
Chapter 3 the most egregious example of
the movie getting weird with its realism
is a character of zero and Natalie
Cooney clown of a villain who feels like
he walked in from a different movie why
can't this guy take a single fight
seriously why is he still yucking it up
with a sword sticking out of his body
even as he teaches on the precipice of
death in a weird way zero and his car
Rad's almost actors audience surrogates
frequently in or of just how much of a
badass John wicker's so far you haven't
disappointed but where did this
phenomenon come from no one in the last
two movies spend this much time
fangirling it up about how cool Jonah's
they were all business sure they
regarded wick as a figure to be
respected and feared but when it came to
be odds with him they fought in like a
pier gin wasn't it the dorks John fights
in the climax of Parabellum don't convey
that sort of vibe at all we know the
world of John wick is larger than life
but in Phil Parabellum but the
characters in that world took things
pretty seriously now at least some seem
very aware of the fact that they're in
an action movie and it makes for a
fourth-wall breaking vibe that doesn't
necessarily work it may be a sign that
this crazy series is on the edge of
getting a little too crazy I'll catch up
with you John
no you won't check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]